all right welcome to Hannity we are back
yes with Incredible live audience whoa
revved up ready to go and coming up the
house Judiciary Committee just announced
that they're going to hold a hearing in
New York City these are the only normal
people in the city
um by the way next week to hear directly
from victims of Alvin Bragg and his weak
on crime policies finally this this city
this state will hear from the victims
their voices will be heard now Jim
Jordan will join us in a minute we'll go
over all the details as Republicans now
fight back against the Democrats witch
hunts later the great one any great one
fans
Mark Levin was here it's way in on how
Biden's weakness is making the world a
more dangerous place and China Russia
Iran guess what they're filling that
void guaranteeing a less Safe America
and a less safe world but first let me
start by telling you briefly let me tell
you what the left-wing media the
Democrats they they want you to talk
about today they have an agenda if we
before we get into the real monologue
they really should be covering that
they're not going to cover the left is
crying racism over the expulsion of two
Tennessee lawmakers last week after they
led a group of protesters through the
state capitol with bull horns uh let me
be clear at this point it's a non-story
when they became state legislators they
agreed to the rules of that house which
clearly State quote members shall not
enter any meeting of the house its
committees its subcommittees join
conventions or joined committees with
props or personal displays of any kind
that maybe be used as a visual aid for
the advocacy of or in opposition to any
legislation or political message
whatsoever in other words you cannot
lead a group of protesters through the
state capitol with a bullhorn the the
way these particular people did now they
may have entered the capital legally but
their actions on the floor uh clearly
created a volatile potentially dangerous
situation for every lawmaker and also
law enforcement also the Tennessee
Tennessee state constitution it gives
each legislature the authority to quote
determine the rules of its proceedings
punish members for disorderly Behavior
with the concurrence of two-thirds they
can expel a member that's what happened
and tonight the Nashville governing
Council has already voted to reinstate
one of The Expelled legislators that's
part of the law also but when the media
mob isn't crying racism uh they're
obsessing over their other favorite
topic and that is they want abortion to
be front and Center even though every
state now will get to make that decision
on their own if you believe in
federalism a Texas judge ruled to
suspend the fda's approval of an
abortion pill but again this too is a
non-story the ruling included an
immediate seven-day stay it won't affect
Most states and because a judge in
Washington by the way Como
simultaneously ordered the feds to keep
access to the pill which the left is
completely ignoring they won't tell you
the whole story they just lie and give
you hysteria and Hyperbole and while
they obsess over these two issues here's
what the left and the mob and the media
don't want to talk about under Joe
Biden's fail leadership the world has
never ever been a more dangerous place
since World War II and that includes by
the way the Cold War and mutually
assured destruction now think about this
all Democrats are out there demagoguing
a new axis of Evil is forming right
before our eyes between China Russia
Iran and guess what the Coalition is
growing on a regular basis and it's not
only posing a threat to the U.S but also
the rest of the world the entire world
take a look at your screen the Chinese
Army released look what they released
here this disturbing video on state-run
television showing what their attack on
Taiwan would look like at State
television the message is unmistakably
clear China is preparing and Ready for
War President XI mentioned it within the
last two weeks uh does anybody have any
confidence at all that your President
Joe will hold them accountable he's
completely powerless didn't even try to
stop a Chinese spy balloon from flying
over the U.S he watched as it flew over
Alaskan airspace and down the coast of
of Canada the western coast of Canada
into Idaho all over the continental
United States over our missile silos
near our military installations and he
did nothing it went to let's see Montana
Anna it went to Missouri went to Kansas
went to Kentucky and then it went out
the Carolinas then they finally took it
down then they still then they took down
three other unidentified objects we
don't know what they are because they
never told us they just spent four
hundred thousand dollars on Sidewinder
missiles but we have no idea what it is
they took down by the way over airspace
so even as NBC News reported the balloon
gathered intelligence from sensitive
military sites sending it back to China
in real time in other words they lied to
us about that too and your president did
absolutely nothing now China faced no
consequences for sending the balloon and
unleashing covet on the world or
constructing blatantly unfair Trade
Practices and of course their
intellectual property theft is too much
to even detail and so much more so what
is Joe Biden he didn't know anything
about the balloon didn't do anything
about Putin taking out a drone what is
he going to do about China's battle plan
to take over Taiwan our Ally in the
region clear clearly China expects
nothing why should they under our weak
frail cognitively struggling president
America sadly has completely abdicated
its role as the leader of the Free World
and frankly the world overall and now
China they are racing to fill that void
along with their new Pals and Russia and
Vladimir Putin and of course the mothers
in Iran and I'm pretty certain that
probably North Korea will be a part of
this axis of Evil in no time at all he
has given up our energy Independence and
a pathetic attempt to appease the
radical climate alarmist religious cult
his obsessive push for all electric
vehicles opened the door for China to
cash in they're making money off of our
stupidity by the way so are the Saudis
so is Vladimir Putin and during the
today's press briefing Kareem
Jean-Pierre was asked you know what the
administration is going to do to prevent
China from benefiting on our green new
energy deal push but as usual she had no
answers take a look at this
some of the companies investing in EV
battery plans here in the U.S are
Chinese companies is the administration
doing anything to stop China from
cashing in on green energy goals I don't
have anything to share on China's
specifically as it relates to electric
vehicles you know our our where we stand
on China we want uh competition not
conflict that's where we have always
moved with China
now meanwhile last month China brokered
a deal between Saudi Arabia and Iran I
didn't think that would happen many are
now speculating that they will throw
their weight into the deal between Saudi
Arabia and Syria now remember under
President Trump's strong leadership all
these countries in the Middle East when
you think of it uh the United States
Israel we had Jordan we had Egypt we had
the Saudis we had the Emirates they all
stood together against Iranian hegemony
well all of a sudden Joe Biden is in
office and the Saudis now clearly made a
decision and Saudi Arabia other
countries made a deliberate choice to
have China negotiate these deals not the
U.S in other words the way I interpret
this is they had bet that China will
become the world's leader surpassing the
United States and they don't want to be
on the losing side of that battle and
now they have shifted away from the U.S
and Joe Biden completely but it's not
just our adversaries that are pushing
back take a look at this during his
recent visit to China a French president
macron warned Europe about America's
weak position as tensions with China
arise and he urged Europe to reduce
their dependence on what he calls the
extra uh territoriality of the U.S
dollar make no mistake a new world order
is forming an axis of Evil is for me and
it's all happening because Joe Biden is
weak and missing in action America is
not only leading from behind we're not
leading at all and the world knows it
and these hostile regimes these hostile
actors they're taking full advantage of
this but I know many on the left they
would rather talk about Republicans or
racist sexist homophobic xenophobic
islamophobic transphobic they want dirty
air and water and they want to kill
Grandma and Grandpa and uh and throw
them over a cliff when they're in a
wheelchair not true hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compel analysis you
will not get it anywhere else